[Music]
who lives in the pineapple under the sea
SpongeBob SquarePants
get ready because we're about to show
you some of the best examples of
SpongeBob SquarePants characters in real
life spongebob how does cracking up so
make sure you watch this video until the
end to see it make sure you hit that
like button and subscribe to our channel
if you love spongebob now let's explore
SpongeBob SquarePants characters and
their real-life look-alikes mr. Krabs
let's start with a character you can't
help but secretly love even though he
doesn't really have the nicest intention
Eugene H Krabs also known as mr. Krabs
he's a greedy money obsessed restaurant
owner but even though he loves money he
avoids spending it as much as possible
his Krusty Krab restaurant features the
famous burger called the krabby patty
which often gets questioned on his
formula while we're at it here's a
real-life krabby patty and we bet you
want to eat one right now since mr.
Krabs is an actual crab this is what he
looked like in real life we can
definitely see the resemblance but mr.
Krabs has more look-alikes than just
animals the internet pointed out the
Clancy Brown who actually voices mr.
Krabs is the best real-life version of
this famous crab character we help clams
he's not as greedy as mr. crabs though
do you know that Clancy voiced the
character for 15 years
Clancy even joked that as he's getting
older he finds more and more
similarities to his crab character he
still has a long way to go before he
starts developing claws red skin and
crab eyes he was also asked about the
secret krabby patty formula but refused
to give any information on what makes
those burgers so delicious he really is
the best real-life version of mr. Krabs
pearl Krabs since we started with mr.
Krabs it's only fair to talk about his
daughter pearl
even though her father refuses to spend
his money pearl does that for him she
doesn't believe in saving and prefers
maxing out his credit card we're not
quite sure how pearl became mr. Krabs
darn in the first place considering that
she's a sperm whale which means that her
mother is probably a whale - so here's
what pearl crabs would look like as a
real-life sperm whale sperm whales can
be up to 59 feet long and weigh up to 45
tons which is pretty impressive a sperm
whale is the same size as a school bus
much like pearl sperm whales also have
almost square shaped foreheads although
they're much more rounded and makes
when you see the size of the thing
unfortunately real-life sperm whales
don't wear cheerleader outfits and they
don't have a heart symbol instead of
their nose this feature is only much
more highlighted with pearl pearl is
voiced by Lori Allen who voiced several
minor characters the movies Despicable
Me 2 toys or III and inside out
Lori herself doesn't really resemble
pearl but she admitted she had an
absolute blast playing a bratty teenager
whale character if you want to watch
just one more video the premium is the
platform where you should go get early
access to videos from the things the
taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place with
ad free browsing click this link to sign
up for the premium and get ready to
binge watch videos from your favorite
channels
[Music]
mrs. puff mrs. puff teaches the
residents of Bikini Bottom how to drive
we've learned to stop questioning why
these characters drive actual cars
underwater
it's just cartoon logics mrs. puff is a
paranoid puffer fish who absolutely low
the Spongebob don't blame her he's hurt
where student and just can't seem to
pass his driving test here's what a
puffer fish looks like in real life
pleasure fish inflate when they want to
run away often there's no actual reason
to do so perhaps this is why mrs. puff
is such a paranoid character they're
also pretty toxic a single pufferfish
can take out 30 people there are
definite similarities between mrs. puff
and an actual puffer fish but we think
there are two humans out there who
perfectly fit her description first is
Donald Trump who basically looks like
her don't you think the two share a
similar haircut and then there's the
lips the face the look the two really
make a perfect match and a second is the
world's most infamous dance teacher Abby
Lee Miller who is known for her mean
teacher role on the hit TV series Dance
Moms we're sure mrs. puff and Abby Lee
would likely have some interesting
conversations about their students
although we're not sure if mrs. puff
would actually be able to handle the
savage that is Abby Lee Miller Gary the
snail Gary made us all want to rethink
our domestic pet choices and go for a
snail instead he had similar mannerisms
to a cat and can sometimes let out an
odd meow this sea snail comes with a
unique pink shell which makes him
instantly recognizable a real-life Gary
the snail would be a typical sea snail
with a hard shell this show actually
protects them from their predators and
is so hard no one can actually really
bike through it they're free to move as
slowly as they want without ever being
in the life-threatening situation pretty
clever right
while sea snails mainly live in the
ocean we also know irregular snails like
this Gary look-alike which run around
the land snails often are the symbol of
laziness but these little animals are
pretty determined think about it would
you be willing to move that slowly just
to get to your destination or would you
just give up Gary the snail is voiced by
Tom Kenny who's also the narrator of the
Powerpuff Girls as well as the actual
SpongeBob SquarePants we'll talk about
him later because this part of the video
is all about the cute looking meowing
Gary
this
nail this real-life gary is part of the
thing called snail art artists have used
snail shells as canvases for years and
give these slow-moving creatures a
unique makeover Squidward Squidward and
mrs. puff have one thing in common
they both have a strong dislike for
spongebob and are too tired of all his
shenanigans we feel you we really do
Squidward Q tentacles is the cashier of
Krusty Krab restaurant and he absolutely
hates his job although you might think
Squidward's is an actual squid he's not
he's been confirmed that he's an octopus
a lot of fans were blown away by the
statement but the fact was actually
confirmed by the creator himself back in
2005 two of his tentacles were dropped
to make it easier to animate which also
happened with Ursula from The Little
Mermaid
check out this surreal picture of what's
good we would look like in real life
this illustration belongs to the website
breaking news and is definitely bringing
a different perspective to this grumpy
resident of the Keeney bottom did you
know that
octopuses are actually super old the
first octopus fossils were discovered to
belong to animal that's almost 300
million years old
no wonder Squidward so grumpy he's
probably experienced thousands of
spongebob like creatures during his time
Squidward is voiced by Rodger Bumpass
who's actually the perfect human
look-alike for this grumpy octopus Roger
also voiced several other additional
characters in some of your favorite
cartoons Roger was actually the one who
evolves Squidward into a sarcastic
character you know today plankton
plankton is one of those antagonists you
just can't help but love he's absolutely
tiny but that doesn't stop him from
trying to find out the secret formula
behind those Krabby Patties of course he
always fails and we love watching him
come up with new ways to trick the
restaurant into giving him the
information he needs most people dismiss
the small creature because of his height
but he proves again and again that your
height should never stop you from
getting what you want
plankton naturally doesn't have the
kindest looking features but neither
does his real-life version plankton in
Greek means wanderer see plankton is
usually very in size but most aren't
bigger than an inch similar to our
plankton in fundable these creatures are
known to turn light into energy and
they're one of the biggest food sources
for other much bigger sea creatures
although Plankton's looks in spongebob
are much more defined a sea plankton
definitely has some similar features
include
tentacle of course you will never see a
real-life plankton speak or even care
about things like Krabby Patties
plankton is voiced by the director of
Spongebob mr. Lawrence
he'll also voiced filbert turtle in
Rocko's Modern Life painty the pirate
you know we have to pay tribute to the
character that starts off the entire
show paint you the pirate also known as
captain starts off the theme song that
many can't get out of their heads once
you hear are you ready kids
you just have to sing along to the rest
of the theme song painty has appeared in
every single episode of the TV series we
bet spongebob fans can instantly
recognize him in any given situation but
there were also spongebob fans who get
the extra mile and recreate painty in
real life
check out this incredibly awesome
cosplay of painty the pirate we can't
even imagine how many times this guy had
to sing the theme song we also
occasionally see patchy the pirate
replaced painting but these two aren't
the same people while patches character
belongs to the voice actor of Spongebob
Katy is voiced by Patrick piney Patrick
is known for voicing Cyclops and
Hercules and he was even the pizza
delivery guy in Toy Story we wonder if
he ever gets tired of being asked to
seeing the spongebob squarepants theme
song but then again how could you ever
get tired of hearing the opening are you
ready kids
aye aye captain she just can't help it
sing along sandy but let's go back to
the main characters of the show
Sandy Cheeks is a squirrel that somehow
manages to live underwater and her
astronaut suit she has a super heavy
southern Texas accent and she's one of
the most intelligent and outspoken
characters on the show while many others
on our list tend to be naive and don't
really think things through sandy is a
talented scientist who's very athletic
and fit it's highly uncommon for a
character to enjoy both sports and
science but sandy proved us all wrong
check out this totally hilarious
real-life recreation of Sandy in the
world of bikini bottom
speaking of squirrels did you know that
the squirrel species grow up to be 36
inches but their average size is only
slightly bigger than a teacup they bury
food in the fall to prepare for the long
winter but the truth is they bury so
much of it they can barely recover all
their treats we don't really see sandy
act like a typical squirrel though she's
best friends with spongebob and somewhat
tolerates Patrick but when you're as
intelligent as sandy characters like
Patrick
you actually get on your nervs Sandia is
voiced by Carolyn Lawrence who's still
best known for her iconic role as the
intelligent squirrel who hangs out with
a sponge Patrick so let's take a moment
to talk about the character that can
sometimes make you pull out your own
hair as you watch him solve problems
Patrick's questionable intelligence
often brings the fun element to the show
but sometimes we just can't help but
worry about his well-being
this pink cartoon starfish is lazy and
his stupidity never goes unnoticed but
at the same time he's the one that
brings all the fun to the show patrick
is actually a perfect representation of
a real-life starfish and they have no
brain no blood and can weigh up to 11
pounds they basically don't do much
during their lifetime but can easily
live up to 35 years which is pretty
impressive
so innocence if a starfish could speak
we imagine it would have the same
characteristics as the wonderful patrick
Star we totally adore his friendship
with SpongeBob and although the two
sometimes do get into fights Patrick
will always come to him for advice he's
voiced by Bill Fagor Bakke who voiced
many other animated characters but none
were as fine as Patrick while bill
doesn't really look anything like
Patrick he wasn't able to truly bring
out the best and sometimes the worst out
of this dim-witted character but the
real star of the show is none other than
Patrick's BFF
spongebob you either love him or you
really can't stand him spongebob is one
of the most unusual characters out there
and it's hard to believe that this show
was created by Murray biologists who for
some reason just wanted to bring life to
a funny spongebob character living in a
pineapple under the sea
spongebob is one of the most
recognizable cartoon characters out
there and is known to be Nickelodeon's
main mascot he's childish but at the
same time he's an adult who has a job
and tries really hard to get his
driver's license
spongebob is a reminder to have some fun
in life whether you're a child or adult
as much as we love this hilarious sponge
looking like the actual character
spongebob was actually inspired by sea
sponges these creatures grow in all
shapes and sizes and can be up to six
feet long there is still an ongoing
debate whether the sponges are actually
plants or animals whatever they are
they're nowhere near as fun as spongebob
this yellow looking sponge with
SquarePants and funny personality really
stole our hearts and brought
interesting twist to Nickelodeon's
cartoons he's voiced by Tom Kenny who
also gave voice to his pet snail Gary
well real-life sponges aren't exactly
fun to look at
spongebob was able to give them a brand
new meaning what's your favorite
SpongeBob SquarePants character let us
know in the comments for more spongebob
related videos check out 10 kids cartoon
characters reimagined as people see you
next time
[Music]